what's up everyone thanks for becoming a  patron it's greatly appreciated we are  now gonna be able to expand our content  line we're gonna be able to make more  highlight reels our productions are  gonna be of higher quality we'll be able  to fly in bigger name guests we'll be  able to slowly but surely build out this  educational database across all these  different subjects and really be able to  inspire people across the world with it  also we'll be able to scale our live  events slowly over time to different  cities across the world as well as  hopefully soon to sports arenas  literally where they play football we  will host massive 50,000 seat events  promoting science technology education  entrepreneurship all these important  things that are building our future so  thanks for becoming a patron and for  joining the family keep sharing the  content with other people keep building  the future yourself keep creating thanks  a lot everyone much love